hey there folks this is vera wilde over
at council of geeks and i'm throwing
this together really quick because i
suspect there are a fair number of
creators out there who probably don't
know this information and it would help
for them to have now if you don't
already know my stuff i run actually
several different channels but my
biggest one is council of geeks where i
talk geeky material but also lgbtqia
plus representation and issues affecting
it in pop media my latest video was an
update on what has been going on at the
bbc and their transphobic news coverage
now something that was brought to my
attention by a friend of mine was that
ads for matt walsh's transphobic screed
what is a woman were playing on my video
not only were they playing at the front
it was actually playing in every single
advertising slot that i had set up
so
this is not a new problem but i haven't
seen it this bad in a while because i've
never heard of the exact same ad running
in every spot so this was something i
needed to deal with and i suspect most
creators don't actually know how to do
this because it's not intuitive you
would think if you're trying to
work on things or restrict who is
running monetization and ads on your
channel that you would do it
from your channel monetization page in
youtube studio that would make absolute
sense
you would also
be wrong youtube is not devoid of ways
to control who is advertising on your
channel but it is buried somewhere where
you probably wouldn't think to look
where you have to go and i'm going to do
this as cleanly and step-by-step as i
can is you actually have to go
to adsense
if you are not
monetized on youtube you may not even
know what adsense is but basically it is
the uh aspect of google the uh i don't
know site app related to google that
handles monetization now it dates all
the way back to when they were
monetizing things like blogs and all the
rest of it but even as youtube became
massive business this is still what
everything runs through
so you need to sign into adsense
and pretty much right away we're going
to get our first annoyance because
if you are like me and have multiple
accounts which i have to have because as
i said i have multiple channels
only one of those is actually a tied to
my adsense
and in this particular case it is the
vera wild account because that was the
first channel i monetized was the vero
wild channel despite the fact that it is
not the largest one that i currently run
in any case
let's log on in here
and here's our first issue
which is that
if you are using
chrome or any other browser in a way
that you are signed into multiple
accounts that you just jump between
it won't let you do it that way you have
to sign out of everything that is in the
adsense account so right off the bat
we've got a barrier of annoyance which
is
actually
surprisingly effective a lot of people
just go oh this is irritating and either
get confused or frustrated this is going
to cause some people to drop off right
off the bat but you need to continue
forward
it's telling me that i'm signing out
sinking is pausing it's going to ask me
do i sign it again to council of geeks
which is the one i use the most uh
actually no i'm not going to do it
because i do that it'll send me back to
square one because it won't let me sign
in as vera wilde if i'm still signed in
with this so instead we hit continue and
we go through this again
hi
adsense now don't worry about these
actual numbers because this is actually
showing numbers um from an old blog that
i used to have that i don't even know i
guess it's technically still up i don't
know so ignore all this ignore all the
dashboard stuff this is not going to be
reflective of any of your youtube's
earned youtube earnings because you go
to channel monetization for that you'll
notice i'm currently getting a notice
that i am signed out because
it made me do it for some
really stupid reason we gotta go over
here to blocking controls so let's pull
that up
and we're gonna head down to youtube
host
and this is gonna be all my channels
because i have all of my channels
monetized through the exact same adsense
account now we have a few different ways
to deal with this
by category broken into sensitive and
general categories or by advertiser urls
stick a pin in this one we will come
back to it let's start with general and
sensitive categories so
what this basically means is you will
not have direct control over exactly who
is or isn't running ads
but
what you can do is you can block certain
categories of ads now it only lets you
do it to the broad categories not
subcategories so you'll notice in the
broad category of say apparel there are
18 different subcategories you cannot
block a specific subcategory but you can
block
or
allow
the entire category now this is the
first thing i knew about this feature
and i had certain things blocked
actually in the sensitive categories
i'll show you that in a minute
but it was really difficult to know
exactly how matt walsh was categorizing
his quote-unquote documentary odds are
it was categorized under arts or arts
and entertainment i'd seen some things
related to him categorized under comedy
which would have been a subcategory of
this and if i block all that that means
that's 23 subcategories of arts and
entertainment so things like movie
trailers um trailers for tv anything
related to that would just be blocked
and those ads wouldn't run which would
i guess work if i correctly
um guess on which uh subcategory or or
overriding category he's running his ads
in uh unfortunately it would be a guess
and it would basically be like it would
be trying to weed a garden with a
shotgun it's gonna probably do more
damage to me than to them so
let's back out sensitive categories now
this i had messed with before and i had
already blocked certain sensitive
categories and these are things that
it is actually kind of nice that google
separated these out from the rest that
these are the sorts of things that folks
tend to be more likely to not want so
things like dating apps drugs and
supplements actually you know what
i'm gonna take that off but i had
already blocked political ads get rich
quick ads religious ads sensationalism
uh
alcohol and gambling so those were
already blocked
on
my channel from being able to run ads
however matt walsh's stuff still slipped
through now here's where we get to the
last thing which is what i hadn't been
making use of before and honestly it's
been long enough since i've had to mess
with this because the last time i had
problems with this was about six years
ago i don't know if this was an option
back then but it is now advertiser urls
and here
you can put in a specific url and if it
is one that is set up to run ads it'll
show up in a search and you can then
block any ad that is tied to that
particular website and business you'll
notice that i kind of have a list of
them here daily wire was the one i set
up initially because that's what matt
walsh is doing his nonsense through but
i basically put in a small handful of
types of media and accounts and
propaganda machines that i otherwise
don't want advertising on my channel
regardless i'll probably make a longer
list this was just what i came up with
off the top my head that i definitely
didn't want running on my
on my channel so
this is where you want to go if you've
dealt with specific categories that you
thought should have blocked stuff but
you're still getting nonsense you don't
want
find out the website that it's attached
to which you can actually usually see
listed
in the advertisement box which
uh it it helps to look and set it up so
you are looking at it from an account
other than the one that uh the
the stuff's actually running on so you
might actually have to sign out of
youtube and then see what happens but
you can find out what dot com this is
tied to and then block it in specific
now this is annoying it's out of the way
we should not be responsible for this we
should have better control than having
to go to freaking google adsense to be
able to do this but we do have the power
to stop them so
go there go to your adsense look at this
stuff set up categories to be blocked
set up specific sites you don't want to
deal with and they will not be able to
run ads on your videos hopefully they
will probably find a way around this and
i'll have to do more stuff in the future
but for right now
that's where we are
hope you found that helpful
and happy pride